key understanding here is that global
warming is slowly warming the planet we
are slowly warming the planet but that
is not necessarily producing this whole
collection of extremes
that the media is has has fixated on the
I like to use the term the golden rule
of climate change and that is the
greater the extreme
the smaller percentage of it is from
climate change natural variability can
produce extremes and so you know we we
go in and out of ice ages that's true
but that does not mean that human cause
global warming is not something that we
should ignore or is or is absolutely
unimportant I I think there's a middle
ground here where the truth is I broadly
agree that that there is a middle ground
and if we heard more from the Middle
Ground the messaging would be more
persuasive I think we're being treated
like idiots